ارطغرل اوغلو نعم. وليس ارطغرل
الذي تظنون وفعلا اسمه الحقيقي.
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين استعداد
انقرة لايجاد حل سلمي للازمة
طائرات بيونج يانج اجرت تدريبات
اطلاق نار جو ارض يا لجرأتك يا
الاوكرانية. وهنا يخرج اردوجان
عن صمته ويقول هناك دول كثيرة
هنا? امريكا تراجع حساباتها
لتعلن ان الجزائر صديقة وتؤكد
الولايات المتحدة ذلك. فهل ياتي
صراخ اردوغان بفائدة لبلاده?
وفنلندا ويظهر كل دعمه لاوكرانيا
لكنه لا يقبل بها كعضو في الحلف.
جسد واحد وامة واحدة مهما اختلف
السياسيون تظل القلوب واحدة.
العمل يعبر عن خطوة عدائية
برأيكم هل تريد اسبانيا ان تتقرب
صرخة تركية. لغة الصمت والحياد
لا تجدي اليوم نفعا. كما ان
بها. في حين تعترف الامم المتحدة
وباقي الدول الاعضاء بجمهورية
عن تقنين مخزونات شهرية من
الامدادات الحيوية مثل الغذاء
ارطغرل. لنكمل. ووزير خارجية
شمال قبرص التركي. يقول ان بلاده
القصة باختصار انقرة تعترف
بجمهورية شمال قبرص التركية
الصراخ ليس ناجحا دائما. احفاد
عثمان في تركيا خرجوا عن صمتهم.
قوة حفظ من قبرص. اردوجان ايضا
لا ينسى قبرص ويؤكد ان لبلاده
منحت الامم المتحدة مهلة شهر
واحد اما ان تعترف بهم او تسحب
وانما لسنوات.
باتجاه بحر اليابان. اكد نائب
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الياباني انه
قبرص الاغلبية اليونانية. ومن
الصراحة الى الوسط حيث ابدى
الواقعة شمال الجزيرة وهي الدولة
الوحيدة في العالم التي تعترف
وبعد ان اطلق وابلا من الصواريخ
خلال اثني عشر يوما. ها هو اليوم
يشعل الوضع اكثر في شبه الجزيرة
الكورية بارسال اثنتي عشرة طائرة
الشمالية. لكن الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي غير طريقته هذه المرة.
سيرد الخصوم بعد اطلاق كوريا
الشمالية صاروخين قصيري المدى
من الجزائر ام لها هدف اخر
برأينا الشخصي? المغرب والجزائر
طائرات مسيرة تتمركز حاليا في
شمال قبرص لكن ما هي قضية قبرص.
ينبغي عدم التسامح مع التجارب
الصاروخية المتكررة لكوريا
الاحداث والتطورات. وبعد ان
تشاوروا لفرض العقوبات عليها
الصواريخ اطلقها واطلقها حتى
يعتاد خصومك عليها. لكن بماذا
كلمة نابية لمسؤول في فلوريدا.
الناتو قبل انضمام السويد
الصحراء الغربية عن المغرب هنا
الحكومة المغربية تصرح ان هذا
متانة علاقاتها معها. وزارة
الخارجية الاسبانية تفاجئ المغرب
لترد بالمقابل بارسال ثلاثين
طائرة حربية ويصرح جيشها ان
كافية لكبح جماح الزعيم الكوري
لتحاشي حرب لن تدوم ساعة فقط
التايوانية تتأهب للحرب كما لم
تكن من قبل. افادت صحيفة التايمز
مستعدة لسد عجز حاجة تركيا
لمقاتلات اس ستة عشر لم تلبي
والطاقة. فهل تكفي هذه لمواجهة
التنين الصيني؟ ساعة حرب. اطلق
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
خلال اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره
البريطانية ان المدنيين في
تايوان شاركوا في تدريبات على
اللهم اصلح شأنهم ولا تفرق لهم.
مايكروفون يفضح بايدن لحظة نطقه
لانقاذ ايطاليا ازمة الطاقة.
بعيدا عن كل التوترات. لربما
داعموك فلتظهر شجاعتك والشجاعة
ليست في الصراخ والتهديدات كما
كيم. ليشكل هنا الكوريون ساعة
مواجهة على الحدود بينهم. فهل هي
شاملة لضمان امدادات غذاء كافية
لشعبها. اذ كشفت وزارة الاقتصاد
انها ليست دائما في الصمت
والتجاهل. هنا الجزيرة
على الموقع الالكتروني للوكالة
للتعاون الانمائي حيث تعمدت فصل
باردا بدون الغاز الروسي. ليصل
الرد الروسي اولا الى ايطاليا
اكدت ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين سيلتقي بنظيره الاوكراني
العقوبات ليس وحده ولكن مع رابطة
الدول المستقلة. وذلك بتطوير
المجال استعدادات تايوان ليست
عسكرية فقط فقد طورت اجراءات
يبدأ عهد المفاوضات بارقة امل
تلوح في الافق. تقارير صحفية
اللقاء بين رأسي السلطة في كييف
موسكو انه اول لقاء سيحدث بين
زيلانسكي في اندونيسيا في قمة
الدول العشرين. الرئيسان قبلا
دعوة القمة بحسب صحيفة ناشونال.
فهل اقترب السلام حقا بهذا
اعمال الدفاع المدني والاسعافات
الاولية باشراف متخصصين في
القادة منذ اندلاع الحرب يا
سادة. التأهب للحرب. اذا كثر
لتعزيز اقتصاداتهم وفق تعبيره.
موسكو لم تقف متفرجة امام
الية بالعملات المحلية وهذا بحسب
بوتين ليس قرارا سياسيا وانما
وزراء ايطاليا جورجيا ميلوني
للوقود الاحفوري ولحل نووي
الجنوبية. هذا الفعل كان
استفزازا مقصودا لكور جنوبية
حربية حلقت في تشكيلات ظهرت فجأة
قرب الحدود المشتركة مع الجارة
وبعد سنوات من تخلصها من
المفاعلات النووية ستلجأ رئيسة
العقوبات لتعلنها اوروبا
بالسنتها. نعم نحن سنواجه شتاء
نعم اكد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سوليفان ان النظر
في عملية انضمام اوكرانيا الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو يمكن ان
للاحتفال بعيد ميلاد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين. وهل كل
الاوروبية. وافق الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الحزمة الثامنة من
هؤلاء هم من سيطفئون الشموع يا
رجل? لا بالطبع بل سيشعلون الارض
طريقة لدعم اوكرانيا هي من خلال
تقديم الدعم العملي على الارض.
والغرب لوحده. وها هو صامد بعد
سبعة اشهر من الحرب. الصمود صفة
من تحت اقدام الزينسكي كما توعد
قديروف. ومن حشود قديروف الجموع
الشيشانية. هل اجتمعوا ليستعدوا
للحرب? لا فقد احتشدت القوات
الروسي. بوتين في المقابل دعا
لاجراءات اقتصادية لتخفيف
اوكرانيا للناتو. لكن مهلا قد
يكون الجهاز الذي يتصل به
ويطالب بما لم يطالب به سابقوه
انه يطالب بتسريع انضمام
العبارة. هنا الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يواجه امريكا
لكن مهلا ما هذه ولم كل هذه
القوات? نعم انها القوات
العقوبات على روسيا بما في ذلك
وضع سقف لسعر برميل النفط
الحل المتوقع لتجنب هذه الكارثة?
كييف لن تنضم للناتو? الكثرة لا
زلاميسكي مغلقا او خارج نطاق
الخدمة. الرجاء المحاولة لاحقا.
لم يتحلى بها بوتين وحده.
زالينسكي ايضا من الاضواء
كرسي السلطة حتى دخل في حرب
دولية لكنه بطريقة او باخرى صمد
ومرت سبعة اشهر على صموده ايضا
ليخرج هنا الرئيس الاوكراني
تغلب الشجاعة وهي ليست المرة
الاولى التي تسمعون فيها هذه
تجرى في وقت اخر اذا فلتحاول مرة
اخرى يضيف وجهة نظرنا ان افضل
المسرحية الى ابواب الحروب
العالمية. فلم يطل نكوثه على
نووية وتحل الكارثة بالقارة
العجوز. يا الهي! بينما لا تزال
جزيرة القرم الذي اصيب بانفجار.
هنا اول قطار روسي يمشي بعد
تحل باوروبا كلها. وبعد انقطاع
التيار عن المحطة النووية في خرج
هذا الوضع لمدة ثمانية ايام. لكن
بعد هذه المدة ستنتشر الاشعاعات
القرم بعد هذا الانفجار ومن
تخلصت منها موسكو الى كارثة قد
جسر القرنة بمثابة اعلان حرب
علنية ضد روسيا. خمس ساعات فقط
ونقلت وكالة تاس عن الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف قوله ان
تصريح عن الشركة المشغلة اعلنت
من خلاله قائلة. بدأت مولدات
انفجرت اشعاعات زبروتشا وهي اكبر
من محطة تشرنوبل باضعاف. فما هو
خارجية متوعدا بان الرد سيكون
خارج حدود هذه المرة فاين ستكون
الانفجار يا للعجب العجاب.
فاصحاب العيون الضيقة لا يلعبون.
الرد من نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما
الذي قال الهجوم الارهابي على
الديزل العمل اليا امدادات وقود
الديزل المتاحة تكفي للتشغيل في
اوروبا تعاني من كارثة تشير نوبل
الى اليوم فما الذي يحدث ان
كانت كافية لاصحاب العيون الضيقة
لاعادة الملاحة على جسر القرنة.
الحرس الوطني الشيشاني مستعد
للسيطرة على حركة المرور على جسر
الضربة القادمة لبوتين? كييف
قالت هذه هي البداية حينها جاء
اذ اعلنت روسيا حركة المرور على
الممرات السليمة من جسر شبه
ويتغنى بنشيده الوطني متفاخرا
بتفجير جسر القرم هنا بوتين لم
العقوبات الاوروبية. ثمانية ايام
فقط على كارثة ستحل باوروبا.
زائفا لا علاقة للايادي
الاوكرانية بصناعته بل هناك اياد
اردوجان يطلق تحذيره للامم
المتحدة. يا للعجب! وهكذا استعد
على اوروبا. واشنطن ترفض طلب
وبوتين يجد الحل لمواجهة
التايوان للغزو الصيني. ومجنون
كوريا الشمالية يغير هوايته هذه
يقتنع بان الاوكران هم من نفذ
هذه العملية معتبرا ذلك نصرا
المرة. والمغرب يعلن العداء
لاسبانيا وامريكا تتقرب من
الجزائر. سرعة التعافي. ها هو
ديلينسكي يضع يده على صدره
الضيقة. فهل استعانت روسيا بهم
في الاصلاح ليكتم العالم انفاسه
وياك
ساعات موسكو تعلن اصلاح الجسر
لكني اشتم رائحة اصحاب العيون
سيكون ردنا خارج الحدود
الاوكرانية. بل تستعد وبعد خمس
وينتظر ردة فعل بوتين. قوات
قديروف تحت شدة وخطة روسية للرد
نفذ الان فورا.
الاستخبارات الاوكرانية تتحدث
معك. انا الان في موقع الهدف.
وهل يكون الدعم بالادوات
العسكرية فقط حلف شمال الاطلسي?